[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Christie Brinkley's daughter Saylor
Brinkley cook dazzles during the season
premiere of Dancing with the Stars it
was surreal it was like definitely
surreal the 21 year old model stepped in
last minute after her mom who was
supposed to be performing Monday evening
suffered a nasty injury during
rehearsals
I think I broke lay on sailor was
graceful and elegant dancing the foxtrot
with her partner Val Chmerkovskiy I
can't even feel this right now on so I'm
so excited by what just took place how
did you guys pull this off we wanted to
do it for Kristy know she was going
through a lot of pain and I feel like us
rallying behind this and making sure we
delivered would make her feel better and
you know every moment that I felt like
giving up and I felt like I couldn't do
it and it was hours and hours of
rehearsal and I just think of my mom and
I'd call her we FaceTime her something
and she'd be sitting there in bed with
her cast on and I'm like she can she can
do that I can do this I just wanted to
show her another standout former
Bachelorette Hannah Browne who
illuminated the ballroom alongside her
partner Alan Burstyn dancing the cha-cha
[Music]
[Music]
how do you think it went tonight I think
it was really good it was kind of
nerve-wracking to be the very first one
out there but it was also such a surreal
experience and I can't wait until next
week to be that and better the highest
score of the night 21 out of 30 went to
james van der beek and his partner Emma
Slater highest score of that that's got
a feel incredible it feels really good
yeah yeah I'm surprised I'm yeah I see
so much potential in him and it makes me
really excited like I can't wait for
this upcoming season it's a lot of
pressure you know a lot the lowest score
of the night went to Lamar Odom he and
Peta Murgatroyd earned an 11 out of 30
for their Foxtrot reaction after being a
part of this and first dance on the
floor this is a challenge probably the
most challenging thing I've ever done in
my life you know basketball came easy to
me was like second nature second game
but this is this is a dimensional
challenge as well as a physical
challenge I kind of anticipated that
from the judges you know it is very
difficult with this height difference
but where we're trying to make it work
he doesn't do this for a living it's
like you know it's so different and he I
was so proud honestly Sean Spicer and
Lindsey Arnold were just one point ahead
of Lamar and peeta their salsa to this
appropriate song got them 12 out of 30
[Music]
it's a reaction to the first stance I
was really happy if you saw where I
started what this woman has done to get
me to today is nothing short of a
miracle this whole thing was about
getting out of my comfort zone I don't
think I'm in my comfort universe and
perhaps the most puzzling moment of the
night when head judge Len Goodman
seemingly shaded Beyonce while
critiquing contestant Allie Brooke
there's a lot of sort of beyond sight
stuff in there which I'm not a fan of
first thing she does when she came down
was a traditional cha-cha step so I'm
like what are we looking at here Yonsei
stop
you wish when Beyonce is in right now
right
[Music]